so I got down on one knee and then she
like what you're doing goes well you
can't be the only one on your knees so
she got down as well yes because she
because she didn't take her yes and we
were in in the Disneyland the happiest
proposal place on Earth
[Music]
[Applause]
to give us a little bit of privacy and
it was just beautiful and she said yes
and then I was like oh okay great and
then it was so overwhelmed that
afterwards we went on a ride this new
ride they had and I kind of collapsed
afterwards because I was so like
overwhelmed with because I'd never been
engaged before or proposed to or
proposed so it was like such a huge
thing in my life and then we went on
this new ride I go hang on I just have
to like and I just like literally
collapsed on the floor for like five
minutes and then I go okay I'm good
let's get chiross